[Music]
decadent burger that we have ever made
starts with
one pound of wagyu on there truffle
cheese gold billionaire bacon on top big
lobster
gold just a bun it is the best burger
you will ever have
[Music]
nina burger having a moment all right
enjoy your burger
who is hungry now the whale burger is
featured in the new netflix show fresh
fried and crispy where host damon drops
hits up all kinds of kitchens across the
country
let's welcome cindy sun the co-owner of
slater's
50 50 which is home to the whale burger
cindy congratulations on the netflix
appearance
have more people been asking for the
whale burger since the episode aired
absolutely we got a ton of phone calls
emails people walking in looking for
the whale burger just you know after
wednesday after the show had
went on netflix and uh yesterday we end
up
selling out of all the lobsters that we
have oh my gosh
so before we break down the whale burger
when did you guys open slaters
we opened uh july in 2018 so about
three years into the neighborhood and so
okay let's break this burger down
because you broke it down on the show
what goes
into the whale burger tell everyone
what's inside this thing
it is in fact probably one of the most
decadent burgers you will ever
see we have one pound of wagyu beef
with truffle cheese on top and gold
billionaire bacon
a six ounce lobster tail topped off with
bacon jam and a gold bun and more gold
bacon on top
and the most important part about it is
served with a bottle of woof
quick wash and paint i love this thing
how do you eat it because
that's in the difficult part you can't
really you pick it up do you get a knife
and fork what's the best way to eat the
whale burger
the best way is really like what they
did in his show
to you know take the greens off and kind
of smush it and
do your best now how does one order
the whale burger here there's a little
trick there i saw on the side of the
table you guys have how do you order
the burger yes so the
the part of the experience is really in
finding the whale the whales as you know
are the high rollers
the ultimate echelon of secret high
rollers here in las vegas they're
kind of hiding in plain sight in the
casinos you don't really know you rub
shoulders with them but
you do not know they're quite there just
like our whale is kind of hidden
in this little artwork that's hidden
around the store and by tapping your
phone on them
it brings the the guests to a secret
website
which would congratulate them on finding
the whale and that is where they can
purchase it and let the server know they
have found it
and it's it just looks it looks so
delicious do you want to tell everyone
how much
it costs because it's a treat when you
do the wild burger you get champagne and
everything how much does the burger cost
hundred dollars great value it's a great
bag it's a big meal
you have cheaper burgers on the menu as
well thank you cindy thank you so much
we appreciate it
thank you all right you can check out uh
the whale burger to make a reservation
just visit their website
mercedes over to you